okay parents you got to listen up here
there's a popular tick tock challenge
and it encourages kids to steal or
damage school property it's happening
across the valley and across the country
many of you telling us on social media
that it's happening at your child's
school here as well bianca holman spoke
with parents and administrators about
this issue
stealing the pencil sharpener and then
10 years later they're still stealing
things because i thought it was okay you
know at the age of 11 through the high
school middle school year so that makes
me i'm really i don't like that it makes
me uncomfortable parents at crane middle
school are warning kids about a popular
challenge hashtag devious lick challenge
on tick tock is getting students in
trouble students record themselves
vandalizing or stealing things like soap
dispensers speed limit signs or fire
extinguishers from school grounds the
goal is to get more followers or social
media clout we are out with our students
every single day so literally first
thing yesterday morning
four students came up to me out in the
quad school leaders were able to connect
the dots between recent vandalism and
the social trend they immediately sent
letters to parents requesting they talk
with their children about this criminal
behavior and this parent we spoke with
agrees support has to come from parents
because school is only a part-time
situation it's about changing behavior
and having students understand the
ramifications of their actions this
issue is popping up as schools across
the valley and the country please
check your child's cell phone check
their social media accounts see what
they're doing
that will help us
here in our education system if we are
not teaching our children they're not
learning from us they're learning from
somebody else
bianca holman there with that story
school leaders say students caught
engaging in this type of behavior face
disciplinary action